l'homme qui est reconnu pour sa passion
sa pugnace cité au parlement d'ottawa
est de retour chez lui
la nation crie est réunie en et masques
à la capitale administrative des cris de
la baie james pour souligner les 40 ans
des implications politiques de roméo
saganash
lorsque j'arrive d'un territoire je
change complètement ça m'apaise beaucoup
de savoir que tous les insectes sont
enterrés quelque part dans ce vaste
territoire
c'était la chasse la pêche le trappage
keat pour moi pendant les sept premières
années de ma vie c'est un essaim mama
de mon existence je me suis senti
vraiment libres de penser justement en
forêt 8 à 10 mois par année
les cris était la seule femme que je
parlais parce que j'étais jeune
jusqu'à l'âge de cet âge que tacot qu'on
m'envoie au passionnant le pensionnat
que l'on venait de construire à la tuque
son frère aîné johnny lui est mort dans
un pensionnat en ontario sans que la
famille soit averti un arrachement
intensifier un an après son arrivée au
pensionnat par la mort de son père
interdiction pour lui et ses soeurs
d'aller aux funérailles
l'avis de roméo saganash bascule comme
le destin de la nation crie l'accord de
la baie james eux sera signé en 1975
c'est l'arrivée d'hydro-québec et de ses
immenses barrage suivi par les minières
les compagnies forestières et la route
du nord la capitale nemaska et la
vitrine de ces bouleversements
le parcours de roméo saganash incarnent
ces changements en 1985 il fonde le
conseil des jeunes de la nation aux cris
puis il est élu vice grand chef cinq ans
plus tard
diplômé en droit en 1989 il devient le
premier juriste d'origine crie en 2002
il fait partie de l'équipe qui conclut
avec québec la paix des braves
donc il avait suggéré aux grands chefs
tels mosus une entente qui laissera dans
les coffres de la nation crie 4
milliards de dollars sur 50 ans je pense
qu'on avons réussi à équilibrer économie
respect des droits des peuples
autochtones et l'environnement quand
elles sont environ une centaine
d'accords ont été signés jusqu'à
maintenant entre la nation crie et des
entreprises comme ici la minière nemaska
lithium situé à 20 km de la commune
c'est jack layton qui converse roméo
saganash de faire le saut en politique
fédérale en 2011 pour le npd et mercy
emmène tous ces grands défis que l'on
retrouve à travers la planète se
retrouvent également dans cette
circonscription qui chez vous après deux
mandats comme député le plus grand
succès en politique fédérale de roméo
saganash aurait été l'adoption par le
parlement du projet de loi c 2 162
visant à harmoniser la législation
canadienne avec la déclaration des
nations unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones malchance la loi saganash
meurt au sénat j'étais bien sûr enragé
pour qu'un et son nom est nu soit et
c'est capables de défaire des des
projets de loi qui ont été adoptées par
là pour l'achat mes gamins le
gouvernement va-t-il travailler avec les
premières nations pour bâtir une
nouvelle relation fondée sur le respect
et la réconciliation
quand on fait comme plus on est bien
contents nous avoir mais quand on fait
du bruit manos les mentalités changent
et et un racisme latent qui continue
d'exister au canada
et aussi au québec il ya un chauffeur de
taxi pendant la crise d'oka qui m'a
carrément demandé de me retourner de
retourner d'où je viens
comment le titre répond nasa ce nouveau
retraité de la politique fédérale n'a
pas l'intention de s'arrêter
la planète est en feu planète sous l'eau
est grand temps qu'on alliès et c'est
pour ça que je vais continuer à
m'impliquer à 57 ans roméo saganash dit
avoir plusieurs offres sur la table
je ne parle pas je ne vais pas il pas
tuer continue à me tenir debout parce
que justement le travail n'est pas
terminé